it is definitely one of one of nature's
special numbers on a par with for
example pie and with e all these these
interesting transcendental in some cases
numbers um
that
crop up time and time again in different
different problems and the [ __ ] and bomb
constant is this universal constant
so what i want to talk about is is a
symbol delta
now that convention is used for very
many different things in in physics and
conventionally means a very small
quantity what i want to talk about it is
is in a different context and actually
in the context of chaos theory so what
it is is something called the feigenbaum
constant
but before i can tell you exactly what
the fagon bomb constant is i need to
tell you a little bit about by curse
theory so you've most people have heard
of cair's theory and have some
understanding of what or
some idea perhaps of what chaos theory
might be in fact case is used in a very
very specific sense in physics generally
you talk about chaos you mean something
very random very disordered and with no
sort of pattern no sense to it all
that is not what a physicist understands
by chaos and we see a very distinct
difference between a chaotic system and
a random system
i think the the the modern understanding
of of the term chaos and the modern sort
of chaos theory if you want to call it
that arose with a guy called edward
lorenz he was a meteorologist and
back in the 60s and he set up
huge supercomputers well at the time
there were super computers in the 60s to
to model actually
meteorological systems through martin
luther to model weather systems out of
his model for example he'd plot this
this function this wind speed or
whatever wind direction as as a function
of time on a you know on an hourly or
daily basis one day he got in the middle
of a run
um say well let's let's use this one um
and he had a
row of numbers representing this this
particular graph and he got to for
example this point what he wanted to do
uh was go and get a coffee so he
wandered off and he got his coffee and
then he set about well let's okay let's
restart the simulation restart the model
from this point and what he did was he
looked at the numbers and to save
himself some time he decided oh well
this is
typed out to six decimal places we don't
really need six decimal places what
difference can you know
the fourth decimal place really make
let's just type this into three decimal
places save some time and um that's what
he did and at the time any physicist or
mathematician would probably thought the
same you know very small changes are not
going to make a big difference but
in fact when he re-ran the simulation
what he found was that well okay it
started off roughly the same but then
remarkably very very quickly and very
dramatically
it followed a completely different
pathway
so
this is
many would would feel at the origin of
this idea that you know if a butterfly
flaps its wings in texas it affects the
the the
weather in london
the key idea here is that this system is
incredibly sensitive to its initial
conditions onto changes in those initial
conditions and very very small changes
blow up rapidly
and a really interesting way of looking
at that really important way is in terms
of population dynamics so let's talk
about fish um and in fact at the
shortly after lorenz did this work um or
maybe even in parallel i can't quite
remember with with lorenzo's work the
the was a lot of work on using simple
models to model the population and how
the population of fish for example and
other animals but let's stick with fish
well so let's look at how the population
varies from from from year to year we
have some particular growth rate which
defines this but let's say that you know
the the at some point um that growth
rate changes there were more predators
less food competition for space changes
and so what we end up with is um a
different growth rate a different number
that controls this dynamics of the
population it's a number it's worked out
by mitchell feigenbaum and it was first
measured by albert libchaber
a wonderful french physicist in
sometimes like 1977. and he took a
a a cell of helium
imagine this box it actually had a width
to length ratio of four to one
um so this is a bit exaggerated and
heated from below
and then the helium rose up and made
circular convection rolls just as you
get convection rolls near your radiator
and these convection rolls stayed in the
cylinder and then a particular
temperature difference between the top
and bottom they started to waggle around
and oscillate with a particular period
and then he heated it up a little bit
more at the top and instead of waggling
around with one period it went waggle
waggle and it took twice as long to go
round and then he heated a bit more and
it went to four times as long and eight
times as long as 16 times as long
if you were to plot a graph because
that's how we physicists work but just
imagine we're doing it and the
temperature difference is along here
you'd start off and you'd have one
period and then it would break into two
it would take twice as long and then
this bit here would break into two and
then this bit here will break into two
and it gets smaller and smaller and
smaller and tinier and tinier and tinier
so you have the first
bit and then you measure this
temperature difference and the next bit
and you measure this smaller temperature
difference in the next bit
so it's as though you're getting closer
and closer and closer to the point where
it's going to take an infinite amount of
time
to repeat the age of the universe and
beyond here is a new monster called
chaos
so what we're seeing here is okay here's
our value of the of the steady state
population at this value of growth rate
2.9 we've got one value now it splits it
splits again and so the magic number
that nature throws out us is if we look
at
the separate i need to draw it suppose
you get to this point and you have a
pitchfork
like thing that is here's a bit of wood
and it goes into two metal prongs and
this bit goes into the length here
and the length here you take a ratio of
these things
the big one over the little one and it
comes out as a number of 4.66 so here's
one splitting here's another splitting
here's another splitting and the fagon
bound consonant
we get from looking at the relationship
of those gaps those splittings and it's
not the key thing is it's not just
populations of fish that this applies to
it applies to systems like for example a
pendulum if you take a pendulum and you
apply a force or variant force to it it
does this periodic doubling route so it
it does this and then it goes into
different modes whereby the period
doubles and doubles and doubles again
until it reaches chaos and where you
cannot you literally don't see a pattern
in the movement of the of of the
pendulum or you could have let's see an
electrical circuit
you have a capacitor with a non-linear
element in there and it will do the same
thing and this pattern of splitting
apart and splitting apart splitting
apart smaller smaller scales occurs all
over the place or in animal populations
so there is something about this
scenario this route to chaos which is
universal and physicists love it when
it's universal because you're not
dealing with a particular problem
you're dealing with something which runs
through nature so this is a marriage
between
mathematics
inventing this scenario and then the
experimentalist albert libchaber very
delicately discovering in the most
unlikely circumstances yes i was invited
over to paris by him first of all to
examine a thesis of one of his students
on vortex nucleation in orifices which
he was also working on i actually spent
some time with him at his house in the
countryside and there's a picture of him
with my son who was very shy with the
camera so he was wearing a snoopy mask
just to make sure the other son also
didn't like having photographs taken he
always stick his tongue out at me
because that particular day he was taken
out by albert who insisted on making
little little boats you know you can
fold these into little boats and every
puddle we came across in the country so
albert would
put this little boat in the puddle and
then we arrived back late for lunch and
i think
that the chico of lamb was overcooked
pie is a big number that we use this is
one of the secondary numbers that we use
that use and it comes to explain these
things it's rather like the critical
exponents in phase transitions these are
very nice attractive numbers but only to
those people in that particular field
it's not as though they affect the
general public